[Musique]
benoît pin est allé à ce tire le coyote
merci de nous accueillir à
saint-élie-de-caxton pour nous présenter
votre cinquième disque au premier tour
de l'évidence et il s'ouvre cet album là
avec la voix de joséphine bacon mes yeux
vie complet est ce que vous vous êtes
imprégné de la culture autochtone pour
une nouvelle chanson ben en fait là où
ça m'en inspirer et fluence et c'est
dans ce rapport l'eau à la lenteur à la
nature aussi ce que j'ai retrouvé
beaucoup dans l'environnement
d'enregistrement ici
je passe beaucoup de temps à
saint-élie-de-caxton depuis plusieurs
mois et dès que j'arrive ici c'est c'est
automatique je me sens je me dépose
personnes
à la couleur du vin et à ce niveau là
c'est clair que je suis très sensible à
la culture autochtone à joséphine entre
qui et qui est magnifique temps dans ce
dans sa manière de rester dans sa son
pouvoir d'évocation finale vous semblez
trempé comme jamais auparavant
je me sens beaucoup plus
ouais c'est peut-être 12,1 et thérapie
aussi qu'il fait n'est ce pas
qui finissent par fonctionner non mais
je vais répondre
oui à ça je suis assez d'accord il ya
tout n'est pas fait et puis c'est sûr le
danger c'est de voir le bonheur comme
une destination alors que c'est pour moi
c'est un long chemin puis puis kiki qui
se veut ancré dans l'acceptation et la
patience puis puis c'est ce que je pense
que je réussis plus le savoir que qu'à
l'époque où j'avais une espèce de de
violence d'agressivité intérieur
[Musique]
faye
baisser
sur votre nouvel album vous avez une
chanson écrite en collaboration avec
l'écrivain robert lalonde et vous
explique que vous êtes toujours comme
robert lalonde à la recherche de la
beauté à travers la douleur ben c'est
pas difficile de ressentir de la douleur
pour moi de le ressentir une espèce
d'anxiété face au quotidien j'ai juste à
ouvrir le journal à regarder les
nouvelles
à regarder certaines manifestations puis
je me sens automatiquement dépassé ma
confiance en l'humanité prend le bar
par contre j'ai ce besoin et j'ai besoin
constant de chercher la lumière et
l'espoir dans tout ce que je vois d'un
peu négatif puis
l'oeuvre de robert c'est ce qu'elle me
fait j'ai l'impression quand j'ai plongé
dans cette oeuvre dans particulièrement
dans ses carnets
j'ai ressenti cette espèce de passé
trouble
agences et une volonté de voir là la
beauté du monde d'observer
dans votre premier recueil de poésie
intitulé la mémoire et une corde de bois
d'allumage vous parlez de l'enfance des
erreurs à ne pas répéter dans quelle
mesure vous avez voulu faire la paix
avec votre propre enfance on se rend
compte en creusant un peu puis sur
l'aspect héréditaire des choses qu'on
est que ces blessures le se perpétue
depuis des générations c'est ce que ce
que j'ai pu reprocher à mes proches mais
il les a reproché à ses parents qu'il
avait probablement reproché à leur parle
puis il arrive un moment où j'ai à
travers l'écriture de ce recueil où je
me suis dit oui mais c c ou qu'une
chaîne comme celle là s'arrête puis s'en
prend pour un super héros j'ai à travers
l'écriture dessus je me suis dit ok je
j'ai envie de débris se briser cette
chaîne la2 de juste
entrevoir un peu d'espoir dans tout ça
puis de léguer quelque chose de positif
et de lumineux là mes propres enfants
je veux revenir sur votre album
désherbage 2010 cet album qui a changé
votre carrière du tout au tout lorsqu'on
crée une chanson comme le ciel est bas
quart d'heure comment on vit avec ça
pour essayer de la surpasser ou
d'atteindre un tel niveau de poésie on
n'y pense pas pour moi le ciel est bas
car c'est une chanson très réussi je
pense le après coup évidemment mais
c'est une chanson qui me fait douter
d'eux avant de la sortir comme j'ai
rarement douter sur une chanson parce
que c'est un sujet difficile à traiter
je savais pas si j'avais trouvé
l'équilibré
équilibre entre la douleur et l'espoir
encore une fois
fait non ça m'a pas traversé l'esprit de
réussir ou non faire quelque chose de
mieux de moins bons mois puis noth alias
tire le coyote merci beaucoup merci à
toi
[Musique]